ivan chaigneau propose voyage sans
passeport cette émission est réalisée
avec le concours de michel angot et de
envie carrier montage yvonne ces restes
sont jean charest illustration sonore de
nice blazer dans la sierra nevada
cette vallée glaciaire au relief arrondi
oui
e
si vous aimez les histoires d'indiens
regardez regardez bien
c'est là qu'il résistait en longtemps
aux attaques des blancs
à côté le séquoia nationale phare fut
aux 2,80 m
les cerfs se cache
ouvrez vos yeux voici le tronc le plus
gros du monde
paysages désolés altitude moins 80 c
death valley la vallée de la mort
il y existe un hôtel il y existe aussi
cette relique ce vieux wagons ce vieux
char de l'époque héroïque utilisé par
les premiers migrants vers l'ouest
roche sans cesse écorché par le vent
tailladée par l'érosion éolienne
dénuement total lave et cendres de ce
volcan grâce à une absence totale de
pluie sont restés dans un état de
conservation parfait
du sable du sable ou une végétation
tente vainement de tenir mais finira
engloutis comme cette manche
vision dantesque le monde lunaire non
tout simplement un ancien marais
asséchés dans le sel s'est cristallisée
selon des formes bizarres son nom le
terrain de golf du diable souhaitons lui
bon plaisir puisqu'il faut tout quitter
quittons ce paysage et c'est vers l'est
dans ses contreforts de montagne qui est
taillée diom canyon site extraordinaire
tous les terrains sont de l'ère
secondaire python murat
au printemps quelques fleurs des lukas
dans les terrains tertiaire bryce canyon
taillé par les eaux de ruissellement
coulante en terrain meuble
i can't rens cette petite bête à gilles
graf yves et douce
e
taillé à pic dans un plateau
uniformément plat le grand canyon du
colorado
des mules peuvent le conduire au niveau
de la rivière
et lorsque l'on remonte l'existant à
mi-août une sorte d'oasis
c'est la cape tisseyre vous attend
la deuxième partie de la remontée est
particulièrement pénible
un observatoire indien reconstitue des
ruines du village indien
et sagesse indienne vivait entre englos
dit et une fois les chaînes tirer l est
dont les atteindre ils se réunissent
encore pour danser
c'est à travers un cerceau qu'il saute
tout autour c'est la désolation seuls
quelques cactées m quand ils fleurissent
une note vivante
et nous retrouvons le colorado
et le boulder dame qui fournit en
électricité toute une région
donc las vegas
l'observatoire du mont palomar